pamela dutkiewicz emmerich 2016
halbfinale olympische spiele in rio 2017
bronze bei der wm 2018
meisterschafts rekord bei den deutschen
meisterschaften und silber bei der em
2000 21 olympische spiele in tokio traum
geplatzt
das ist einfach ein erneuter schlag also
ich habe meiner sportler karriere schon
ganz viele rückschläge erlebt und weiß
wie man mit mit bruststrecken umgeht
aber das war einfach nur noch ein kampf
das war auch irgendwann so ein krasser
mental körperlich
ich bin die letzten monate auch viele
viele monate zum training gegangen und
wusste nicht ob das gut geht
wenn ich dieses video von kerner ins
programm sehe dann geht mir das ganz
schön unter die haut und zwar aus zwei
gründen erstens weil ich selbst mal
leistungssportlerin und kenne dieses
gefühl und zweitens bin ich eng mit penn
befreundet wir waren in einer
trainingsgruppe viele jahre lang
ich habe danach den olympischen spielen
2012 aufgehört und sie hat weitergemacht
bis heute tokio sollte eigentlich dieses
jahr das ziel sein das hat nicht
geklappt stattdessen ist sie in bochum
und er damit beschäftigt sich körperlich
und seelisch aufzupäppeln
und ich fahre jetzt gleich zu ihr und
sprecht mit ihr darüber und vor allem
über das große thema druck im
leistungssport den sie ja trotz all der
starken moment und erfolge immer wieder
gespürt hat bis es irgendwann auch nicht
mehr ging
[Musik]
druck im sport das betrifft viele
sportlerinnen und sportler die klein zum
beispiel wenn man im verein sport macht
aber vor allem auch im spitzensport kann
sich da auf ganz verschiedene art und
weise äußern darüber sprechen wir in
diesem video noch genauer aber jetzt
treffe ich erstmal perman bochum
ich bin gespannt wie sie heute geht weil
sie neben video bei instagram ja von
krasse mentalen druck spricht ich weiß
der ist zu einem gewissen teil normal im
sport aber kämpfer jetzt ganz schön am
ende wenn wir so viele rückschläge an
ein kurzer zeigen dieses ewige auf und
ab erlebt dann macht es natürlich auch
was mit deiner seele und mir hat es
schon ganz traurig und ganz viel zweifel
und so und ich mag es tut mir auch nicht
gut wenn das jetzt angst vor mir ist
voll auf dem bild auf gekloppt ich habe
mich gefühlt wie sind weiß ich nicht ein
fuchs der auf die andere straßenseite
wollte schnell und angefahren wurde
und da liegt und probiert seine wunden
zu lecken um nach auf die andere seite
noch diesen wir diesen olympia zug noch
irgendwie zu erreichen
und irgendwann geht wer sich dem einfach
und genau so fühlte sich das an einfach
so dem druck dem kampf jetzt einfach ja
sich hinzugeben
das war's also hat sie es ein bisschen
angeführt wie wie aufgeben dass es nicht
geschafft und mixes waren aufgeben
mit einer enttäuschung verbunden aber es
war eine große erleichterung weil dieser
druck über so ist man ja so komprimiert
dieser druck war immer acht monate und
ich hatte gar keine zeit des aufatmen
also es war zwar im training und es lief
nicht gut ich bin
ich bin irgendwie danach war ich mehr
patienten als als sportlerin das heißt
ich bin das dann in jedem wartezimmer
war ständig konfrontiert mit schmerz
ständig konfrontiert mit die zeit läuft
ich will ja irgendwie noch zu den
olympischen spielen kommen aber aktuell
merklich dass der weg ich komme da nicht
mehr auf den weg der da vielleicht noch
hinführen würde es gab ja auch so
situationen wo du im training folgen
guten leistungen hat ist aber im
wettkampf kommst du das nicht ab woran
lag das
wenn man das ist ja immer die große
frage wenn man dass man genau wüsste
woran hat es gelegen dass wir
deutschland wurde aber das also ganz
klar ist wichtig ist dass man körperlich
gut trainiert ist dass es die nummer
eins aber im riesengroßen anderen anteil
hat natürlich für die mentale leistung
das fokussiert bleiben dass bei sich
bleiben das bündeln dann das perform
wenn es drauf ankommt und ich hatte ja
du warst ja sogar dabei wenn es im
wettkampf das ein ganz schlimmer
wettkampf das war ja das war ich wollte
mein comeback feiern nach einer großen
verletzungen konnten weil es vor
heimischen publikum so einschlägt wird
jetzt vorher noch nicht gab
also soviel tool so viele leute die ich
kenne alle wollen jetzt nicht am meisten
dass das irgendwie gut funktioniert und
das war's also das waren 1 maximale
blockade ich hab plötzlich kein zugriff
mehr auf meine körperlichen bewegungen
gehabt ich habe keinen zugriff mehr auf
mein gedankenkarussell das kennen wir ja
alle
wenn nun erwischt wirst und zu krass
nervös bist dass du nicht mehr nicht
mehr stoff sein kann es jetzt ruhig und
dann kommt ja einige teams eine richtige
spiralen ich kann da nicht mehr raus und
ich war überall aber nicht bei meinem
lauf zwei jahre vorher hatte genau das
total gut geklappt wm 2017 im flow
em bronze ich hab ja dann nach dem lauf
in london direkt im anschluss ein
anderes mädchen gemacht und saß dann im
flieger leben robert harting
wer dann zu mir gesagt hat mädchen
genießt das mal das wird nicht so schön
ich habe das gar nicht so richtig
verstanden und das jahr darauf da war ja
natürlich berlin und der
europameisterschaft im eigenen land ist
man mit ja sie ist riesengroß gemacht
wir waren wie so kleine stars und jeder
hat erwartet also wer im jahr vorher bei
einer wm medaille macht der macht auch
eine ebene medaille
und ich habe den rucksack echt gespürt
da war so viel druck so viele last mit
der ich gelaufen bin ich finde übrigens
auch dass man das in dem laufen sieht
dass das nicht ein leichtfüßiges das war
eigentlich muss das jetzt machen ich
will das jetzt auch machen und dann war
es eher so vor dem druck fällt ab was
sich hinter dem ziel weil dieser
cocktail know how das ist eine
wahnsinnig lade der a44 klein also in
london bis ins ziel gekommen und dachte
oh mein gott dass ich geschaffen und in
berlin bis ins ziel kommen was gedacht
was je erfolgreicher camp wurde desto
größer wurde auch der druck die
erwartungshaltung steigt die eigene und
auch die der anderen
damit muss man umgehen können was dabei
helfen kann ist die arbeit mit
sportpsychologen
deshalb habe ich darüber auch mit der
sportpsychologin marion sulprizio von
der sporthochschule köln gesprochen
wie ist das denn mit druck im
leistungssport klar ein stück weit ist
er ja normal aber blockiert er denn oft
athleten dass die ihre leistungen nicht
abrufen können
also das ist ja ein phänomen was gar
nicht mal so selten ist sondern die
athleten berichten häufig dass sie eben
aufgrund von druck ihre optimale
leistung nicht abrufen konnten und das
liegt eben daran dass bestimmte
situations bedingungen aber auch die
bedingungen die man selber in seinem
kopf schafft also die gedanken und die
gefühle dass die dazu führen dass man
für die optimale leistung einfach falsch
aktiviert ist also ich würde mal sagen
falsch in dem sinne dass man hier zuviel
aktivierungen verspürt also dass man
einfach zu aufgeregt ist zu nervös wird
und dann geht es mit der leistung den
bach runter so kann man das eigentlich
ganz einfach erst mal erklären
druck hat viele verschiedene gesichter
eins davon kann ein gestörtes
essverhalten sein
experten gehen gerade bei elite athleten
von hohen zahlen aus bei athleten wird
der anteil an gestörtes essverhalten auf
45 prozent geschätzt
bei athleten auf 19 prozent wir haben ja
auch zusammen gewohnt und als ich das
erste mal gemerkt habe bei perl ist noch
mal ein ganz anderer druck war als das
thema essen bei dir so groß war in einem
alter wo ich jetzt rückblickend sagen
wir das ist einfach viele athletinnen
sind weiter oder nicht manche ein
bisschen mehr babyspeck was ich
irgendwie noch entwickler gemacht so
gesetzt sein
sie sind also eigentlich nichts
tragisches aber mir wurde von meinem
trainer schon signalisiert dass es zu
viel und auch ganz offensiv und mit
wenig gefühl
dann wurde ich ohne dass dies wusste
bewogen um zu reden
ich trete nicht an welchem tag das ganze
passiert das war natürlich dazu geführt
dass ich wahnsinnig unregelmäßig
gegessen habe oder getrunken habe was ja
eigentlich ist wenn man leistung bringen
möchte und den körper muss man ja
energie zuführen vorher
wir wurden tipps gegeben die eigentlich
keine tipps sind also ist man apfel und
und vielleicht auch schon aus rum dass
man ja auch wenn ich abnehmen möchte
also das heißt mit richtigen ich habe
keine lösungsvorschläge bekommen cam hat
daraufhin über jahre viele verschiedene
methoden ausprobiert ernährungs buch
diäten shakes ich weiß noch ich hatte
geburtstag und dann habe ich zu meinem
geburtstag ein käsekuchen bekommen und
dann war nur und gesagt kann ich es
jetzt den käsekuchen und dann haben wir
uns beide ein stück käsekuchen
reingezogen und fanden
richtig toll und ich weiß noch am
nächsten tag hattest du so ein
schlechtes gefühl du wusstest ich für so
ein ernährungs buch du musstest an sich
einschreiben und dann musst du rein
schreiben nur kuchen gegessen
scheiße kiesel und gegessen das antrat
ich weiß ja weil ich war in so einem in
so einem konflikt dass ich wusste ich
bin so diszipliniert ich mach das was
diese ernährungsplan mir vorgelebt und
es funktioniert mit und in dem moment in
dem ich dann natürlich stück käse kommen
was eigentlich nur verwerflich ist aber
es war außerhalb der gp2 würde
vielleicht zeigen da haben wir doch die
erklärung dafür warum es nicht aufgeht
also das war mit charme und mit so wenig
ich mache es ja richtig und es
funktioniert mich und ich bin mich nicht
bloßstellen lassen
ich habe mir so etwas nicht erwartet
unser trainer hat gesagt du musst
gewichtig schaffen bis zu dem und dem
wettkampf und dann machst du mega
geschwächt weil das ich und ich
erinnerte mich noch super g haben es
mussten 66 kilo dann bist du schnell
ich hatte keine energie weil es ist doch
logisch also brauchst du weißt du
brauchst der energiequellen damit dein
körper über muskeln aufbaut und das
erste was der körper hergibt es seine
muskulatur und speichert die fed also es
war komplett bekloppt herangehensweise
ich hatte keine energie ich stand ja
möglichst am startblock hatte das
idealgewicht und kam hintereinander war
eigentlich kaum nach 100 metern und 10
würden
und was hat dieses 60 kilo müssen seien
mit dir mental gemacht hätten vertrauen
wolltest das erreichen
aber was hat das für die wirkung auch im
hinblick auf druck vielleicht bei dir
hinterlassen wir total also ich hatte
maximaldruck maximaler druck
neben einer trainingsleistungen auch
noch den körper auf ein minimum
eigentlich zu bringen was er gar nicht
möchte und ich habe ja auch im nachgang
wahnsinnig lange probleme gehabt also es
war so viel stress und so viel druck
über eine lange zeit dass ich lange
gebraucht haben intuitionen gefühlen der
leichtigkeit in der ernährung das was
viele andere haben was was einfach wie
sie passiert problematisches verhalten
ist ja schon länger ein thema
sport was wird denn in der
sportpsychologie dagegen getan
bei unserem coachings geht es dann
tatsächlich wieder über die schiene
wie kann man selber den athleten stärken
dass er mit bemerkungen beispielsweise
von trainern oder von presse oder nehmen
wir mal social media also wo man ja auch
ständig bewertet und unten unter den
fotos irgendwelche aussagen geschrieben
werden die auch hat sind sowas kann man
natürlich eher lernen mit solchen
bemerkungen umzugehen dass eine
möglichkeit für die athleten
die andere möglichkeit ich war ja
irgendwo ist es ja auch ein dickes fell
zu haben also sich wirklich klar zu sein
dass in bestimmten sportarten dieser
punkt kommen kann und dass man dann
vielleicht auch lernt zu sich selbst zu
stehen also zu dem eigenen körper zu der
eigenen entwicklung zu stehen und das
selbstbewusstsein zu haben okay dann bin
ich halt fünf kilo mehr dann muss ich
halt in einer anderen rasse antreten
aber auch das werde ich schaffen
vielleicht nicht direkt ist von anfang
an bin ich nicht gerade der weltmeister
europameister aber ich kann mich wieder
rein arbeiten weil ich die techniken und
die taktiken drauf habe also das könnte
schon hilfreich seien solche gedanken zu
schulen und zu entwickeln
die meiste zeit hat termin in
vergangenen 15 jahren hier im
lohrheidestadion in bochum verbracht
manche trainingseinheiten auch gemeinsam
mit mir aber perm hat sich hier auch
manchmal her geschleppt obwohl sie
wusste dass ihr körper gesundheitlich
noch nicht fit genug ist
ich musste mich schon häufig über
körperliche signale die musste ich
ignorierte ignorieren musste ich drüber
hinwegsehen und wusste eigentlich
bräuchte das muss vielleicht noch zwei
drei tage aber ich hab' ich muss jetzt
halt gucken dass ich irgendwie nicht so
sehr belastet vielleicht bestimmte
übungen weglasse aber ich muss im
trainingsprozess vorankommen
mittlerweile hat viele jahre mit
verletzungen hinter sich bänderrisse
muskuläre probleme körperliche
verschleiß und auch in diesem jahr kam
so einiges zusammen so dass penns körper
eigentlich nicht mehr mitmachen konnte
nach tokio reisen zu können hast du da
nicht auch so ein paar sachen ignoriert
absolut ich glaube es war nix aus dem
was wir gerade angesprochen haben also
ich hatte
ich hatte keine zeit ich wusste ich kann
den körper nicht ganz heilen lassen dann
kann ich auch gleich lassen
ich muss jetzt einfach irgendwie einen
weg finden aber dann muss natürlich
andere körperregionen wie kompensieren
und irgendwann haben sie auch keine
kosten an können nicht mehr dann total
der bereich also es war eigentlich nur
sein es hätte gut gehen können
aber es ist nicht es gibt ja nach einer
verletzung einmal den faktor ich muss
ganz schnell wieder fit werden und dann
gibt es den faktor
er schaffe ich das überhaupt nach dieser
auszeit wieder
und daran wird ja auch in der
sportpsychologie gearbeitet
ja also die sportpsychologie ist nach
den verletzungen halt sehr gefragt die
mentale verfassung wieder auf super
anstatt zu denken
bei hoffentlich schaffe ich das jetzt
nach meiner verletzung brauche ich einen
positiven gedanken wer zum beispiel sagt
ich traue mir das zu ich habe gut
trainiert ich bin gut drauf alles fühlt
sich gut an
das sind so dinge die man auch wirklich
gewinnen sie eine kleine kopfarbeit kopf
hausaufgabe trainieren kann druck findet
hauptsächlich im inneren stadt aber eine
quelle kann auch die außenwelt seien
sponsoren vereine verbände manager alle
haben ein interesse an ihrem erfolg sie
sind ein teil von diesem ganzen system
und sie unterstützen mich erhoffen sich
natürlich auch ein erfolg und zu einem
gewissen grad gibt es auch verträge in
denen steht du gehst dann und dann am
start wenn du gesund ist und was und das
wird gemacht
das heißt es ist eine ganz klare
geschäftliche geschäftliche
vereinbarungen die man da ein geht klar
man steckt als athlet in irgendeiner
form auch in abhängigkeiten und entweder
du kannst als athlet ich da ganz klar
und frei man sein ist egal was ihr meint
irgendwie ist es dreht sich weiter und
es gibt so viele andere athleten aber
ich hab dann schon eine form von
verantwortungen gefühlt als du dieses
video gemacht hast dass wir uns vorher
angeschaut haben indem du
ganz authentisch und transparent zeigt
wie schlecht es dir ging hast du dir da
auch sorgen gemacht wie diese außenwelt
wie die reagieren werden
ja schon also ich war schon verunsichert
und deswegen habe ich dich ja auch
gefragt was du sagst weil wir sportler
uns ja eigentlich nur als helden zeigen
das ist einfach so ich hab mir schon
gedanken gemacht wie reagieren die
anderen und du dachtest du bist nicht
die helden wie du eigentlich sein willst
in dem moment ja oder die man die
sportler zu sein also in der
außenwahrnehmung ist der sportler der
held ist er ist stark muss funktioniert
alles und der liefert aber dass dieser
teil eigentlich noch viel viel größere
ist das scheitern ist viel größer als
die positiven momente des kalenders
probleme haben das zweifeln dass nicht
viel viel größeren trainingsalltag oder
generell viel größeren teil 1 als das am
schluss sich eine medaille
anscheinend ist die außenwelt aber auch
bereit für diese seite der medaille für
den druck und das scheitern
zumindest die sportfans auf games video
gab es bei instagram ganz viele positive
rückmeldungen und empathische worte also
krise welche rolle spielt denn die
außenwelt im sport das kann als mit
einem athleten machen was macht auch
wieder sehr individuell unterschiedliche
dinge
wir haben athleten die finden das gut
wenn die so ein bisschen gepusht werden
wenn die druck kriegen wenn die
vielleicht auch diesen spruch kriegen
dann sind die erst recht motiviert
aktiviert und das läuft super und bei
anderen geht es nach hinten los deswegen
ist es ja auch immer sehr wichtig dass
der trainer für jeden athleten auch
seine eigene individuelle ansprache
wählen kann dass man seine athleten gut
kennt und genau das gleiche passiert
wenn beispielsweise in der presse das
ist ja auch druck von außen wenn da
geschrieben wird na ja der ist noch
nicht fit oder wie sieht der denn aus
oder er hat ordentlich zugenommen
dann ist für den einen jahr der punkt wo
man sagt naja an euch zeige ich jetzt
erst recht und das finde ich wirklich
gut dass ihr auf mich so guckt und
jemand anders sagt nein
das netz zu viel da fühle ich mich stark
unter druck das habe ich nicht und mit
dem müssen wir arbeiten mit dem ersten
ja nicht dann wird sein
ding machen und derjenige der aber dann
unter diesen äußeren druckbedingungen
leidet mit dem kann man sport
psychologisch arbeiten also druck es
nicht immer nur die last und der
gegenwind die uns langsamer machen er
kann auch unser rückenwind sein unser
antrieb unser motor das sagt auch per
ganz klar glaube es braucht diesen
cocktail an ich bin nervös ich habe eine
hohe erwartungen an mich von außen ich
hab dann team hinter mir und die wollen
es natürlich auch irgendwie also so ein
positiver druck
[Musik]
daraus entsteht höchstleistung und die
erfahrung habe ich auch gemacht
also es ist ich glaube jetzt im
rückblick es gibt auch nichts schöneres
als wenn du ein ziel hast du arbeitest
daraufhin biss nervös alle wollen
irgendwie dass es gut ausgeht und dann
funktioniert das ganze auch ich würde
fast sagen ohne diesen druck wer
höchstleistung mich möglich man hat also
einen weg gefunden wie sie druck
zeitweise auch positiv nutzen konnte und
vielleicht möchte ihr das auch weil ihr
druck in irgendeiner form empfindet und
das muss nicht nur im spitzensport seien
unter zu viel druck steht man wenn man
an sich selbst bemerkt dass
beispielsweise die muskulatur fest wird
dass man anfängt so ein bisschen zu
hyperventilieren dass das herz rast was
man magenschmerzen bekommt dass man
komische gedanken hat die einen stören
und dann auch so was wie ängstlichkeit
und nervosität entwickelt hat auf
solchen schwierigen drucksituationen
einiges mitgenommen und hat auch ein
paar tipps wenn ihr druck empfindet und
performance abliefern müsste dann ist es
total wichtig dass eure akkus geladen
sind also dass ihr wisst was sind eure
energiequellen und ich habe zb
herausgefunden
für mich ist es total wichtig auch mal
abstand zu nehmen also ein buch zu lesen
gute gespräche zu führen mit freunden
also einfach ganz klar den druck mal
wegzuschieben nicht nicht nicht prozent
zu haben
und wenn dann dieser tag kommt an dem
ihr per formen möchte
hilft es mir zum beispiel total im hier
und jetzt zu sein also wirklich wenn in
meinem fall beim warm-up und ich mache
gerade in den übungen da mache ich diese
den übungen auch gedanklich und bin ich
fünf schritte weiter und es kann helfen
wenn man den zettel habe ich auch immer
dabei sich einen zettel schreibt und
wenn man irgendwie merkt so das
gedankenkarussell fängt an und ich
schweife ab sich den zettel zu holen und
dann steht da sowas wie sie jetzt hier
und das kann immer ein guter anker sein
wenn man unsicher wird versucht auch
jetzt wieder ihren anker zu finden
wieder zur ruhe zu kommen sich um ihre
gesundheit zu kümmern denn darauf kommt
es jetzt an jetzt wo der traum von tokio
schon geplatzt ist
[Musik]
wie geht es denn euch mit dem thema
druck im sport schreibt uns eure
gedanken unten in die kommentare
und ganz wichtig die seit damit nicht
allein wir haben euch in den text unten
nochmal anlaufstellen gepackt wo ihr
hilfe bekommen können